the headlines arguing convince the red
alerts it's hard to ignore how gun
violence has become an all-american news
staple so is it time we stop treating
gun violence as a front for an
ideological war and start treating it
like a public health issue if that
sounds crazy just look at cars we do a
lot for car related violence as a public
health issue that we don't for gun
violence for instance yes we've got a
lot of statistics on gun violence but
what we don't have is a national
database of information on every single
gun death in the country we do however
for every car death whenever someone is
killed in a car accident
everything from the speed of the car to
details about the tires to the make of
the car are entered into a national
database that database heavily informs
what car safety standards and policies
look like the sort of policies that have
reduced the deaths per mile by more than
90 percent we're talking speed limits
seatbelt safety glass airbags child
seats even highway dividers but we don't
have that devotion to gun deaths and
that's thanks in large part to the
powerful lobbying of the NRA in 1996
Congress passed an amendment that banned
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention from funding any sort of
research that would advocate or promote
gun control and in April 2016 over 100
medical and public health groups issued
a letter calling for increased federal
funding of research into gun violence
the letter referred to gun violence as
an epidemic and if the opinions of those
in the medical and public health fields
don't convince you well the stats on gun
violence are compelling while gun
homicides and violent crime overall have
gone down the leading cause of premature
death in the United
States is gun-related surpassing car
deaths making gun violence a public
health concern doesn't mean we're
arguing about whether guns are
constitutional or not the Second
Amendment isn't going anywhere
but looking at gun violence through the
lens of public health means it becomes
possible to one push for funding for
research into gun related deaths and to
create policies for gun safety that
reduce death and injury and that can
work in promoting car safety no cars
were banned conditions were put in place
that make driving a car safer and for
public health groups it's the same for
guns they don't want to ban them they
want to control the factors that make
gun violence as deadly as it is factors
like background checks gun seller
licensing funding for mental health and
funding for research on gun violence
itself so then treating gun violence as
a public health concern bring together
people on both sides of the gun control
debate